le personnel de réanimation pédiatrique
de l'hôpital Clocheville était en grève
aujourd'hui à Tours cet après-midi ils
se sont réunis devant l'établissement
pour protester contre le manque
d'effectif et demander plus de
recrutement romain Delville était sur
place
avec le soutien de collecte d'autres
services de représentants syndicaux de
la CGT les personnels de la réanimation
pédiatrique de l'hôpital Clocheville
sont venus dire leur ras-le-bol
ras-le-bol d'être appelé même pendant
les repos ras-le-bol des congés
maternités non remplacé des journées de
12 heures de voir les collègues pleurer
qui craquent parce que trop fatigués
sans arrêt de changer de planning on est
même appelé déjà deux heures avant qu'on
embauche
on est toujours à essayer de faire et
puis bah nous c'est pas dans notre
dans notre volonté de vouloir faire
grève ni mais là c'est qu'on peut plus
quoi on a pu nous ces solutions on veut
avoir on veut être normé on veut pouvoir
travailler bien on veut surtout prendre
en charge nos enfants bien une bonne
prise en charge et surtout les familles
aussi qui nous entourent parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'il y a tout un
ensemble aussi selon les agents du
service cela fait un an que la
réanimation pédiatrique est en
souffrance le recrutement de remplaçant
est difficile et une fois arrivé la
formation des protocoles en pé pour être
complète et sûr et longues et
compétences ça demande du temps pour les
acquérir ça demande du temps aussi il
faut avoir une une maîtrise et la
maîtrise ça s'apprend pas comme ça en
deux jours ou même quand il y a un
sous-effectif c'est extrêmement
difficile de former donc des nouveaux
arrivants des nouveaux agents puisque
déjà comme on est en sous-effectif on a
une charge de travail qui est importante
le personnel a voté la reconduction de
la grève une grève travaillée mais un
mouvement pour tirer la sonnette
d'alarme auprès de la direction